you don't know everything about me
The Avengers weren't my first family at
some point we all have to choose between
what the world wants you to be
new your nope
our secret finds its way out they'll be
the death of him this was your choice
[Music]
this summer my dad believed in you
I'm not gonna make the same mistake you
know what happens to you if you don't do
this I have everything I need to have
the court-martialed and dishonorably
discharged
Ronnie we got some kind of fire we got
units headed out there now don't know
why he came all the way up here he won't
survive
[Music]
Klose guides six of our northern cities
and fallen in a coordinated attack their
leader fights alongside a witch
crush these murderers your majesty every
family must contribute one man to fight
your war hero you've already made many
great sacrifices
my father cannot fight so I will take
his place the northern invaders will
kill her if I expose her power all
people will kill her when we take the
Imperial City I will take revenge for my
father what is your name soldier
Wai ghin commander so no Poirot you will
now take the oath of the warrior
release
[Music]
[Music]
by pretending to be something you're not
yet here I stand proof that there is a
place for people like us
a girl threatens our plants
[Music]
a warrior
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
vision residence
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
when it comes to sweet there's only one
name I've studied the best spinach his
legendary I raced the fastest in the
world he makes us all its left I'm wild
but he's on another level that dude he
knows it's all about the rings when he
turns on the burners good luck
he's just a blur out there what's this
for again what's this for again this
Morgan what's this for again great
question I have no idea but please
McCaffrey go on about how amazing I am
what am i doing mine hog
now that's what I call good cop bad cop
left herself open I used to live my life
a quarter mile at a time but things
changed my father now I will always be
in your heart
little Brian I have a gift for you your
daddy gave me this no I'm gonna give it
to you it's very special it's for
protection from what's coming
all right down what's next no matter how
fast you walk
I am not to be compared to you know not
rugs their past and mine
just caught up to me there's a long time
down so we're up against a master thief
high-performance driver
whoo easy
[Music]
Jacob is Tom's brother your whole life
you pushed yourself to be faster than
Donna smarter than down stronger than
time but could you kill him
[Music]
because I'm ready if you are there's
nothing more powerful than the love of
family you turn that into anger there's
nothing more dangerous maybe this is the
end but we won't go out together you
know I dragged to the death with you
[Music]
it's good to work please tell me that's
not a pontiac fiero
strapped through a rocket engine
impressive i no no no that's that's not
impressed
I came here to take you down a little
cause that's your mistake
this is my world
damn they got a magnet plane hold on
tell me we're not thinking what I think
you're thinking there's no bridge
he'll not
[Music]
hey guys surprise
nice Clubhouse
if we do this we risk everything
[Music]
the commercials in this game are really
expensive it's just the pregame yeah I
smell a road trip there could be my
breath the Spongebob movie sponge on the
run yeah that was money well spent
you